we saw her on camera the last image of
hers on camera
with a bag of food and her eyes looked
so sad i kept asking myself why
her why couldn't have been me
instead of her
we've seen a lot of african-american
girls that have gone missing
and very little visibility is
brought to their case for
two weeks we said she did not run away
every two weeks to keep saying she ran
[Music]
away
[Music]
on january 12 2018
my 16 year old niece jolie moussa went
missing
she came home with her sister and then
was getting some random text messages
from
somebody we don't know who and at that
moment in time she was like i'll be
right back i gotta go i'll be right back
unfortunately for us she never came back
when we're telling the police that
there's
definitely something wrong she would
never be gone like this
and completely stop communication what
we then heard was
right now it looks like she left of her
own free will
she's a runaway with the use of that
word
there was no further action being done
on her case
for two weeks we said she did not run
away
and for two weeks they kept saying she
ran away
she had been um discarded
in the woods like yesterday's
trash
if they had not said she was a runaway
if law enforcement had started looking
for her more urgently
at the time we reported her as missing
could they have found her alive
[Music]
jolie was murdered by an ex-boyfriend
who had previously assaulted her
nebu ibrahim strangled jolie and hid her
body in a park in a statement the
fairfax county police department said
jolie was initially reported missing on
january 13
and our officers immediately began
investigating
ibrahim was promptly identified as a
person of interest in her disappearance
every piece of technology
and resource available to our department
was deployed to solve this case
why would the police look at a young
black girl and think
she's more likely to be a runaway than a
young white girl
there's just a certain level of
prejudice
you know that still kind of hangs in our
culture in the united states
across america the statistics on missing
children show a shocking
racial disparity only 14 percent of
children in the us
are black but 37 of missing people
under 18 are african-american of all the
kids that go missing
over 90 percent are runaways according
to the national center for missing and
exploited children
most of these issues with young people
who run away
they're usually running from
a condition or running to a condition
meaning someone's luring them out
r-e-l-i-f-h-a
this is eight-year-old relicia wood
that's good
i can hear him laughing she was
interviewed by a homeless charity in
february 2014.
try to give us some place to stay she's
talking about the shelter where she
lived in washington dc
say it louder a shelter give her some
place to stay
four weeks later she went missing you
on it
this is relisha and the shelter's
caretaker khalil tatum
walking into a motel room relisha hasn't
been seen
since
you have a flyer sir yes okay so please
keep an eye out for religion
i kept asking myself why her why
couldn't have been
somebody else why couldn't it be me
instead of her
religion didn't like staying in the
shelter did she finish a call in the
trap house
what did she mean by that when they say
the trap house
because either drugs is being sold
around
or near it was horrible
rats stink lice
nasty it was just so much going on in
terms of
the quality of care and resources food
the food there was horrible i heard
religious rule didn't want to eat there
sometimes you would
want to go with somebody else just just
to really get something good to eat
over at dc general you've seen a lot of
things
that a child should not see they was
exposed to a lot of things
khalil tatum killed himself a month
after this footage was shot
and the police still don't know what
happened to relisha
her family cling to the hope that
someone will come forward with
information
about their little girl and her
community worries
about the many vulnerable children like
relisha
sadly a number of children that are part
of the lower economic standings in our
community
they aren't taken as seriously what
we're noticing is there are a number of
homeless children and children in foster
care that are being victims of sex
trafficking
and sex trafficking of our children is
taking place around the country
like atlanta chicago baltimore and
overwhelmingly african-american victims
absolutely there's a disproportionate
number of african-american girls and
boys who are victims of sex trafficking
so i was 14 and
i had this boyfriend who was 28 years
old my parents on my 14th birthday
wouldn't let me stay out past 9 p.m
and so i called him and he said pick you
up in 15 minutes
don't take anything so i think that's
the number one thing what we call kids
missing
that would appear to be me running away
at 14 no child can consent to getting in
the car
with an adult period so it's actually
called kidnapping
when i was 15 they did a raid and when
they did a raid i told the police i was
15. i set my real age and i actually
said i had a pimp
and so i was arrested and put in
juvenile detention
for a year but there are other survivors
that speak out
um who are caucasian and one of the five
she's a good friend of mine
she got found in tennessee she's
originally from virginia
when she got found in tennessee at 15
the police drove her
home to virginia and i got arrested and
charged
for prostitution
on the story that has shocked people all
across this country thousands of
volunteers have been looking for her for
weeks
that the coroner has identified i don't
think the media
cares more about the white child i think
media definitely airs what they think
people are more interested in
so it's a byproduct of what goes on in
the world
so what the world has shown pretty
consistently throughout the years is
that
black children are lesser valued
don't they're not cared about as much
although black children
are over-represented in u.s statistics
on missing children
they are underrepresented in the news
headlines
a study in 2015 found that 35
of kids that disappeared were black but
only seven percent of media stories on
missing children
involved african american cases media
used to call me and ask me for a white
survivor that was 13 years old and i'm
not making that up
people would say this to me like no i
get the numbers on the african-american
girls tina
but tell me how many caucasian girls do
you get
some of the looser statistics do say 73
percent
of trafficking survivors in the u.s are
people of color
am i taking the flyer if a white person
went missing
you see all this rigmarole all this
media all this hype
and then you look next door and it's a
black person missing under the same
conditions
and they didn't get that henderson long
comes out night after night to look for
missing people in washington dc's
poorest
and majority african-american
communities
you know somebody's child right he works
for free having experienced his own loss
his aunt aileen went missing over two
decades ago
and never came home a teenager
i got my first crash course to be out
talking to
dope dealers prostitutes drug addicts
you name it residents police officers i
got a chance to see how it feel
to be searching trying to find your
loved one
these folks they don't have any money
they don't have somebody
to come and advise them on that case to
be a liaison between them and the police
department
we have families that literally will
call us before calling the police
and filing a report they're distrustful
of the police
because of previous experiences or what
they've seen
on the news or just personally seen it's
not all police departments it's not
every police person it's not
there are many kids for whom the police
report is done
impeccably but there is definitely
inherent bias hello you see a higher
volume
of lack of jobs okay thank you
appreciate it you see that
education is far inferior to all other
areas
you see a lot of domestic violence you
see
a higher number of missing persons
missing from these areas
there needs to be more sensitivity
training but it takes
all of us law enforcement the community
and our media to bring awareness to and
help find our missing
racism is everywhere i think it's in
every part of our society
i think no one is exempt not the mayor
not the president
it's not something to deny we got to
fight it that's what i would say
to anybody
you